but your YouTube channel is CV 77 gaming
is that right yep great okay you want to
just say your name and your age and
we'll go too long bend wake up at age 11
weston McWilliams age 11 I'm exact obits
and I'm turning 14 like three days so I
lobster 13 hockey booth I hokay my name
is Nathan and I'm not okay great and you
guys all do the channel together or this
was your initial it was I kind of like
started off the team and then these
these guys actually aren't players but
they're like managers and stuff so that
they help me run the team yeah and
what's the premise of the channel what
what do you do what we do like call of
duty competitive a lot like Call of Duty
the video game game plays and stuff like
that okay and compete compete against
other teams oh I see okay and these are
videos that you make yeah into okay
interesting um when did you start the
channel around early july this year yeah
yup 2013
Wow and did you look at other channels
for research did you like this and and
you saw what you liked and and what did
you see from the other channels that you
like that works to get them subscribers
and views I know just like promoting
themselves like making trap like going
on to other channels and saying hey we
just made a new gaming channel or check
out or like you know kind of just
promoting people a lot of times stuff
like oh I'm ready nice and so right now
how many views do you have channel views
and how many subscribers think we have
around like 350 channel views and then
like 46 subscribers or something okay
very nice um what are some of the things
you like about having your YouTube
channel and then one do some of the
things that are maybe more of a chore
that's it's not so fun it's not so
flowers well I like making the videos
and kind of like interacting with all of
the people on the team and all that kind
of stuff but one thing I don't really
like is kind of editing I don't really
like it kind of takes forever and I just
I computer like always freezes and all
that kind of stuff it's just it's just a
house what are you used to edit my movie
how I movie okay we also do have a team
editor read it's like really high
performance things so yeah and what's
your ultimate goal with the channel you
are you guys just doing it for fun or
have you seen you know the Shane
Dawson's the yea or you trying to get up
there of course but like right now we're
just trying to do it for fun but like if
we make the breach of getting up to
there we may make a ticket like pretty
seriously like really serious
but we'll still do our jobs that we
wanted to do like when we go off we can
you choose i was like a side thing or
something so yeah mm-hmm what do you say
to the idea that oh there's some people
that actually make their living off of
youtube would you be willing to put in
that kind of time because I'm sure it's
years and years and a lot of time behind
the I've to govern in there any of you
guys know but I mean a long time to get
this subscribers that we have right now
by Facebook it's about slide yeah I
would try to like give shoutouts and
everywhere we feel like here social
media places and all that yeah I like I
was running out of ideas yeah then
VidCon jump graph right now and I'm
pretty sure we should get more
subscribers yeah because we sort of
passing out business cards and I've been
calling like here you sure to passing
out like like promoting here kind of
like saying like hey check out this
channel would you call of duty videos
so it seems to be helping out so yeah
you